At this plenary session we voted for the
farm-to-table strategy, the objectives of which are
shared by our political groups, the
Socialists, we have identified the
possible problems and difficulties
generated by these changes. For this reason, we
believe it is important that the commission
prepare impact studies of all the
measures that are developed based on  In
this strategy, the final result is
not what we socialists would have wanted,
but it is where we have
found the balanced political agreement by
adding elements such as the
importance of innovation,
labeling of origin, integrated production,
etc. It is essential that
the impact of this strategy does not
prevent  agricultural markets remain
stable with fair prices
throughout the entire food chain,
starting with the farmer, if
this objective is not achieved, fraudulent practices could increase
food production and we are also concerned that
the strategy
in which  the co  competitiveness of
european productions compared to
imports from third countries whose
producers are not subject to these
requirements
bolt seen by james in investments
the center for strategic is the
european green pillar of the origin or destination of the
euro
benítez change the baby prius in
food consumption  of things there were not literal and
sting the future of generations torkham
in mit the north of raids of the show the
project is of euros profits from the
uniforms
of consuming the health and quality food
producers with fire and protection
against the competition and the
investment readiness pressure from
farming